bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir l'étoile montante ou l'étoile
filante de la droite bonsoir Aurélien
pradiier et merci beaucoup d'être notre
grand témoin ce soir vous prenez la
plume pour la première fois avec
tenirbon chez bouquin un autoportrait à
la fois personnel et sensible on va en
parler un brin narcissique aussi vous
nous direz à 38 ans jusqu'où va votre
ambition tout à l'heure notre grand
débat ce soir faut-il boycotter la COP
28 Dubaï capitale de la desmesures au
Moyen-Orient s'apprête à accueillir la
conférence internationale sur le climat
mais déjà de très nombreuses ONG
critique le choix de cette ville alors
comment parler urgence climatique dans
l'un des principaux pays producteurs de
pétrole de la planète nous en débattons
dans un tout petit instant sur ce
plateau avec mes invités enfin nos
affranchis ce soir l'économie Olivier
l'international Vincent UG et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée signée Elsa mondain Gava
voilà pour le programme on y va au rien
Prad ça vous regarde ça commence tout de
[Musique]
suite on a connu des choix beaucoup plus
consensuel Dubaï avec ses gratciel
climatisés et ses laques artificiel
devient donc la to la capitale de la COP
28 à partir de ce jeudi les Émirats
arabes unis pays haut de cette grande
conférence mondiale pour le climat
est-ce bien raisonnable et à quoi
servent aujourd'hui ces grands
symposiums bonsoir Jean-Marc zuli
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes député renaissance des bouchees du
rô et vous présidez à l'Assemblée la
commission sur le développement durable
bonsoir Sophie talier poanons bienvenue
vous êtes député écologiste du valde
Marne bonsoir pierre larouurou ravi de
vous accueillir eurodéputé de l'Alliance
progressiste des socialistes et des
démocrates à Bruxelles signataire de
cette tribune qui rassemble beaucoup
d'ONG appel au boycott tribune publié
dans le monde enfin bonsoir Léa Falco
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
membre du collectif pour un réveil
écologique et chroniqueuse le vendredi
action planè c'est vous le visage de
l'écologie dans cette émission Aurélien
Pradier évidemment vous intervenez quand
vous le souhaitez on va commencer par
planter le décor Dubaï bon ou mauvais
choix c'est avec Stéphane blackakovski
mon complice de tous les soirs le chrono
de blackco pour
commencer bonsoir mon cher Stéphane
bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors cette COP 28 écoute la COP 28
écoutez familier malgré toutam la C 28
elle ne commence que jeudi mais ce soir
sur LCP quasiment en exclusivité
mondiale je peux déjà vous donner le
bilan de la COP 28 le bilan sera mitigé
et oui c'est c'est mon petit doigt qui
me le dit non pas du tout regardez j'ai
regardé le bilan des dernières COP il y
en a tous les ans donc la COP 24 bilan
mitigé la COP 25 bilan très mitigé al
après il eu les COP 26 COP 26 là le
bilan était plus que mitigé mais à la
COP 27 ça allait un peu mieux parce
qu'il était simplement mitigé alors ça
veut dire quoi mitigé ça veut dire que à
la suite de chaque conférence sur le
climat il y a du bon et du moins bon euh
et d'ailleurs le magazine britannique d'
économiste a fait une une assez amusante
à ce sujet il a fait le comme un
bulletin scolaire des dernières
conférences sur le climat donc
l'appréciation générale c'est quelques
progrès mais doit faire mieux donc il y
a des notes un peu précis sur les points
forts les points faibles donc le gros
point fort des conférence sur le climat
noter B+ c'est ve dire entre 14 et 16
prendre des engagements
là le le le point un peu plus faible
c'est keeping to commitment c'est tenir
ses engagements là c'est à peine la
moyenne donc voyez c'est assez bien
résumé les les difficultés qu'il y a
dans les C7 et encore à peine la moyenne
c'est bien noté parce que en fait si on
regarde les objectifs fixé par la COP 21
2015 pour
les les atteindre pardon en 2030 il
faudrait réduire de 43 % les émissions
de CO2 or sur la trajectoire actuelle on
ne les a on ne les réduira que de 2 %
vous voyez que l'écart ne mérite
peut-être même pas la moyenne si je vous
donne la courbe c'est pour visualiser
l'effort que ça nécessite la petite
courbe noire c'est les émissions de CO2
qui ont évolué jusqu'à là il y a deux
solutions réduire la température la
hausse maximum de température 1 de5 ça
serait la courbe bleue donc vous voyez
l'effort que ça demanderait réduire à 2
degrés cette courbe là bon dans un cas
comme dans l'autre moi je ne sens pas
tout à fait prêt pour faire ce genre
d'effort maintenant ça n'empêche pas
d'écouter les encouragement de jaier
guterz qui est quand même le secrétaire
général de l'enu on
écoute ça veut dire des plans nationaux
pour l'ensemble de l'économie avec des
objectifs clairs pour 2030 et 2035 afin
de contenir la hausse 1 et préparer le
terrain à la fin des combustibles
fossiles alors vous avez entonu Antonio
guz il faut mettre fin au combustible
fossile effectivement c'est sans doute
la meilleure solution parce que je peux
encore vous montrer un graphique
rassurez-vous ce sera le dernier voyez
quand on examine les émissions de CO2
les émissions humaines de CO2 en tout
cas la part des énergies fossiles et en
premier le charbon qui reste vraiment
les principaux responsables donc comme
vous le disiez organiser la COP 28 aux
Émirats Arab Unis qui sont le 7e
producteur mondial de pétrole c'est un
peu bizarre surtout quand on voit que en
fait le président de la conférence sera
en plus et toujours le le président
pardon de la principale compagnie
pétrolière d'abouabi alors évidemment la
question du boycott se pose faut-il
aller se coller les mains sur le bitum
s'accrocher quelque part avec un antivol
bah Greenpeace a déjà dit que c'était
pas une bonne idée de boycotter c'est la
même avis que exprime François gemen qui
était membre du j qu'on l'écoute on sera
à un endroit où il ne sera plus possible
de tourner autour du pot et donc en
quelqu S sorte organiser la COP 28 à
Dubaï c'est aussi prendre le taureau par
les cornes et discuter directement avec
les pays qui ont fondé toute leur
économie sur l'exploitation de ces
énergies fossiles et des
hydrocarbures bon ben voilà donc je
voulaai dire la COP 28 commence donc
jeudi le bilan sera mitigé ça c'est sûr
est-ce qu'il sera mitigé très mitigé
est-ce qu'il sera plus que mitigé mais
là il y a un débat il est taquin ce soir
merci beaucoup merci Stéphane je
commence avec vous ver la routurou
pourquoi pour vous tout simplement c'est
désastreux ce choix de Dubaï parce que
est-ce que est-ce qu'on accepterait
qu'un fabricant de cigarettes organise
un congrès de lutte contre le cancer
est-ce qu'on accepterait en 2023 des
fabricants de cigarettes disent quelles
sont les études dont on débat quels sont
les textes qu'on va rédiger qu'on va
voter à la fin du Congrès non
aujourd'hui les fabricants de cigarettes
n'ont plus le droit pas un seul d'être
dans les réunions organisé par l' le
fabricant de cigarettes en question
c'est les Émirats arabes unis euh qui
vous disent c'est certes on produit du
pétrole mais beaucoup moins beaucoup
beaucoup moins Contin les années 70
c'était 70 % du PIB aujourd'hui j'ai
regardé ça n'est plus que 17 % mais mais
à la limite que ce soit à Dubaï déjà ça
assz choquant tout le côté artificiel
les inégalités voilà mais ils auraient
pu mettre un ou une climatologue dans ce
pays aussi il y a eu des inondations
terribles il y a quelques mois il y a eu
5000 personnes déplacées Dubaï aussi est
touché par le dérèglement climatique
mais maîre comme patron de la COP 28 le
patron de la plus grande entreprise
pétrolière et en plus la BBC vient de
nous apprendre qu'il profitait de son
rôle de patron la COP 28 pour continuer
à faire des contrats de GNL et de
pétrole c'est absolument scandaleux donc
nous ce qu'on demande attendez alors là
vous expliquez peut-être nos
téléspectateurs n'ont pas vu ce papier
de la BBC donc en fait la BBC nos nos
confrères britanniques montrent que ils
profite de ce grand de ce grand
rassemblement d'ONG et de et d'État pour
signer des contrats des contrats
d'hydrocarbures c'est ce que disent vos
collègues de la BBC qui sont des gens
assez sérieux et assez sérieuses qui ont
les preuves il y a des preuves qu'il
utilise son agenda il est là comme
président de la COP 28 et il en profite
pour pour négocier avec tel ou tel pays
le fait qu'on va leur fournir du pétrole
ou du gaz liquifié donc vous dites n'y
allez pas moi ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut boyotter on vient de lancer un
appel sur une COP sans pétrole demander
au chefs d'État de dire qu'on n'ira pas
dans les réunions avec ce sultan c'est
vraiment scandaleux c'est la caricature
les lobis du pétrole se croient tout
permis ils ont jamais été aussi
puissants mais avoir le patron d'une
entreprise pétrolière comme pris dans la
COP 28 et qui négocie des nouveaux
contrats c'est inacceptable et on
voudrait que ce soit la dernière COP où
les pétroliers peuvent être présents
déjà l'an dernier c'était à la COP 27 il
y avait plus de 700 lobbyistes et tout
monde avait dit c'est pas normal et donc
est-ce qu'on peut tellement ils sont on
est dans la caricature changer les
règles du jeu et dire je le répète de
même que les fabricant de cigarettes
n'ont plus le droit non mais c'est tout
à fait sérieux
l'OM fabriquant de cigarettes n'a plus
le droit de se promener dans une réunion
sur les questions de santé on voudrait
interdire définitivement les lobes du
pétrole à la prochaine COP Jean-Marc
vous allez y aller vous accompagnez le
chef de l'État non non non moi j'ai
décidé de ne pas y aller tout simplement
parce que j'ai fait le choix d'aller
plutôt à la COP biodiversité avec une
proposition de résolution pour être
utile dans le cadre des négociations
pour le coup là nous n'avions pas de
proposition de résolution et j'ai
considéré que la place de la commission
était plutôt de faire des auditions en
ligne de sorte à à limiter notre bilan
carbone moi je considère qu'il ne faut
pas boicotter il faut savoir dénoncer et
je trouve que vos arguments sont justes
il faut uvrer pour changer les règles je
pense notamment sur la place des
citoyens dans le cadre de ces
différentes copes mais aussi sur des
engagements beaucoup plus forts de la
part des états parce qu'il ne s'agit pas
de partager un bilan mitigé une feuille
de papier avec une signature il faut que
il y ait de vrais engagements avec des
bilans notamment dans le cadre de
planans qui soit développé et suivi par
la représentation nationale par les
citoy faut des d'autres d'autres
rencontres avec peut-être les plus
volontaristes des pays on va venir sur
les alternatives possibles à ces bilans
mitigés systématiquement chaque année
des des cops vous dites que il y a la
main des lobbies dans dans ces cops des
des énergies fossile notamment à Duba je
pense qu'il faut savoir rééquilibrer
justement rééquilibrer la main de ces
lobby en donnant beaucoup plus de place
aux associations en donnant beaucoup
plus de place aussi à des entreprises
qui sont vertueuses qui sont qui ont la
volonté de changer leur modèle
économique et que nous soyons en
capacité aussi d'intéresser nos
concitoyens dans nos circonscriptions
parce que la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui lorsque vous parlez de la
COP 28 dans nos circonscriptions et bien
ça ne parle pas nos justement on va
essayer de faire un peu clair Sophie
talier po quand on regarde la carte
regardez Dubaï c'est tout petit hein
c'est de la taille du bénéuxe 9 millions
d'habitants percuté de plein fois il
faut le dire quand même par le
réchauffement climatique avec des
canicules évidemment l'été pas de fleuve
pas de rivière du gaz et du Pétrole
certes produit en moins grande quantité
qu'il y a 30 ans mais quand même est-ce
que pour vous c'est mettre le renard
dans le poulailler que d'aller à Dubaï
écoutez le renard est dans le poulailler
des copes depuis le départ donc ce que
nous voyons voyons là avec cette COP
finalement c'est montré au grand jour
toute cette forme
d'hypocrisie qui a consisté à finalement
se dire que dans le cadre du système tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui on peut affronter
les défis du dérèglement
climatique bon donc que cette COP ait
lieu là c'est symptommatique
finalement oui c'est symptommatique de
cette forme de de en fait de de de
méthode qui pour le coup aboutissent à
des bilans tigé enfin moi je veux dire
insuffisant extrêmement insuffisant par
rapport à la gravité de la situation
dans des grandes villes d'Europe ou de
mais cela dit une fois que j'aiou
d'Amérique du Nord avec des bilans
mitigés c'est pas forcément lié à
absolument c'est ce que c'est bien ce
que je dis c'estàd que là on a quelque
chose qui donne à voir de manière
vraiment éclatante toute toute la le
problème fondamental qui qui qui est
celui de des des cops dans la façon dont
elle se déroule aujourd'hui et qui
aboutissent à des résultats qui sont
très largement insuffisants une fois
qu'on a dit ça et qui on l'a dénoncé je
pense qu'il faut le dénoncer euh je
pense quand même qu'il faut y aller ah
pourquoi pourquoi je pense qu'il faut y
aller et bien parce que euh nous devons
être en soutien euh aux pays les plus
touchés aujourd'hui par les dérèglements
climatique qui sont les pays du Sud euh
nous devons être en soutien euh
vis-à-vis d'eux et la France doit et
j'espère qu'elle portera euh un message
très fort pour faire en sorte que les
fonds promis par les pays occidentaux
qui ont été je dirais à l'origine de ce
gigantesque anthropocène par la
l'industrialisation massive par le
développement bien de ce du capitalisme
aujourd'hui que l'on voit elles doivent
porter secours à ces territoires et donc
moi je ne pourrais pas dire il y a de
l'hypocrisie donc je boycotte non nous
devons devons par solidarité aussi par
solidarité des dommages les fameux
dommag parce y a des enjeux très forts
et avec les ONG nous devons vont pas
laisser les lobbyes seuls donc bien sûr
c'est une c'est le d'y aller mais par
avec un esprit très fort de résistance
alors un mot lea Falco sur Armen
aljabber sultan Ahmed c'est son prénom
aljberber qui est donc le président de
cette COP il est aussi ministre de
l'Industrie mais surtout c'est le PDG de
la compagnie pétrolière d'Abu Dhabi lui
dit je suis mieux placé que les autres
pour embarquer tout le secteur des
hydrocarbure et et des énergies
carbonées et donc faites-moi confiance
qu'est-ce que vous répondez oh bah je
pense qu' il fait tous ici une confiance
aveugle hein à ce monsieur non mais le
le enfin la nature de la COP c'est une
nature diplomatique donc ça veut dire
que derrière vous avez forcément tout un
tas de pays différents qui viennent en
coalition plus ou moins affirmé et qui
ont chacun leur agenda donc évidemment
que les pays du Golf aujourd'hui les
pétromonarchies arrivent avec un agenda
qui est on veut poursuivre le
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures enfin
c'est intéressant dans les priorités de
la COP il y a pas écrit réduire la
production d'énergie fossile il y a
écrit réduire les émissions de co2d
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez en fait deux
grandes visions du monde vous avez une
vision qui est celle des Émirats arabes
unis et par ailleurs de l'ensemble des
pays producteurs qui est de dire ce
qu'on va faire c'est complètement
décorréler l'utilisation des énergies
fossiles des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui vont en découler et donc pour
ça notamment il se base sur tout un tas
de technologies qui aujourd'hui sont pas
matures à l'échelle ne sont pas déoy à
c'est des technologies de caption de CO2
en fait ce qu'on veut atteindre nous
c'est la neutralité carbone et donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'on ait une
équivalence entre les émissions de CO2
au niveau mondial et les puits de
carbone qui sont soit naturels donc ça
c'est l'océan ça c'est les forêts c'est
tout ce que vous voulez et des puits de
carbone qui peuvent être artificiel
technologique et pour lesquel
aujourd'hui typiquement stocker le CO2
dans le sol et aujourd'hui on on ne sait
pas faire ça à l'échelle internationale
donc il une forme d'hypocrisie complète
pour bah disons que c'est c'est normal
c'est c'est leur c'est littéralement le
PIB et l'économie de leur pays que de
vendre du pétrole mais donc là la
question aujourd'hui c'est comment
est-ce que la France comment est-ce que
l'Union européenne comment est-ce que
les pays des Nord aujourd'hui proposent
une alternative pour les pays des Sud à
ce développement là parce que je vous
rejoins absolument dans le jeu
international aujourd'hui les pays des
Nord l'Union européenne ne sont pas
dominants on est très dépendant de ces
pétromonarchies parce que toutes nos
infrastructures sociales reposent sur du
pétrole sur du fossile et en plus tous
ces pays qui veulent nécessairement
avoir un développement et qui devraient
avoir un développement décarboné qu'on
devrait pouvoir leur fournir n'ont pas
d'autre choix aujourd'hui que de se
tourner vers ces pays-là qui en plus en
profite évidemment largement en
multipliant les accords bilatéraux en
multipliant les investissements question
positionn EUR com on arrive à aller je
pas d au passage que tout le monde va
prendre l'avion hein que ce soit les
dirigeants les ONG présents ou pas dans
le casadre des négociations pour pour
aller passer cette semaines ou quelques
jours à Dubaï comment on choisit et
comment on fait pour que les pays des
Nord comme vous dites et à Falco
reprennent la main pour imposer leur
méthode leur agenda je suis pas sûr
qu'il faut que ce soit le pays des Nord
qui prennent la main fa construire avec
avec les pays du Sud ENF je veux dire et
donc il faut bien que ça tourne aussi au
niveau
géographique si on se dit que on va
réduire enfin anéantir les le
dérèglement climatique juste parce queon
va les dirigeants vont arrêter de
prendre l'avion enfin c'est pas sérieux
donc il faut des grandes réunions qu
vous entendez les Falco qui dit qu'à
Dubaï on fait de la géoingénérie c'est
ça c'est ces nouvelles technologie qui
permett de capter de après effectivement
il y a quand même ce débat de savoir si
la technique va encore nous en fait
c'est une fuite en avant une fuite en
avant dans la science comme progrès
absolu et donc on va trouver des
réponses techniques qui vont régler le
problème le problème c'est de ralentir
le problème c'est de réduire notre
l'empreinte humaine euh par le fait de
choisir les activités que nous voulons
qui soit bénéfique socialement c'est ça
le Laou peut-être qu'on peut avancer sur
qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre de de
cette réunion parce qu'à chaque fois on
nous dit euh des engagements nouveaux
euh toujours que voilà l'objectif de de
parvenir aux accords de Paris semble
inatteignable aujourd'hui d'ici la
neutralité 2050 ça semble très compliqué
euh la neutralité carbone donc des
engagement nouveau on on est déjà dans
l'adaptation on est déjà dans la
réparation pour les pays les plus
impactés mais à chaque fois rien de très
contraignant non rien de très
contraignant surtout que là on a
l'impression que les fous ont pris le
contrôle de l'asile voir le patron d'une
entreprise de pétrole qui est le
président de la COP mais c'est une
caricature c'est un cauchemar il y a
quelques années on ils ont trop de place
l'an dernier on pensait que le grand
sujet à la cop27 ce serait comment on
sort du pétrole parce qu'il y avait eu
un rapport qui avait fait beaucoup de
bruit la plus haute autorité mondiale la
l'autorité internationale de l'énergie
l'Agence internationale avait dit il
faut stopper tous les nouveaux forages
de pétrole en disant on a encore besoin
de d'essence pour nos voitures mais avec
les forages existants il y a assez de
pétrole pour les 20 ans qui viennent et
donc la plus haute autorité mondiale
avait dit il faut stopper tous les
nouveaux forages de pétrole donc on
pensait il y a un an que ce serait le
grand sujet de la cop27 et les lobes du
pétrole ont obtenu qu'il a pas une ligne
sur le sujet pas une ligne et le sultan
qui préside cette année l'an dernier a
dit ah il est pas sultan je précise he
il s'appelle sultan Amed c'est son
prénom pardon un point pour vous pardon
euh excusez-moi mais il avait dit devant
avant tout le monde j'étais à la COP 27
on avait été frappé par son cynisme il
avait dit il faut continuer 600
milliards d'investissements dans le
pétrole chaque année donc la planète est
en feu là il y a dans le Nord pas
decaléis des inondations catastrophiques
il y a eu des milliers de morts en Libye
avec la tempête voilà toutes les
semaines on parle de l'urgence
climatique et bien vous avez un un
président de la C 28 qui l'an dernier
encore disait il faut continuer
d'investir sans problème 600 milliards
par an donc je voudrais insister sur le
cyisme en France quand Emmanuel Macron
dit il faut accélérer on n'est pas bon
il faudrait baisser de 5 % nos émissions
de CO2 chaque année la conférence de prè
du président - 5 % 3 jours plus tard
Patrick pouyanet c'est un immense joig
d'honneur monsieur pouyanet nous dit que
Total va faire plus 3 % le contraire de
pétrole chaque année le président dit il
faut faire - 5 % chaque année - 5 % et
le patron de Total dit je continue à
faire de plus en plus de forage plus 3 %
chaque année c'est un cynisme terrible
et au niveau européen j'arrive de
Bruxelles pour votre émission il y a 30
ans il y avait un grand projet il y
avait deux grands projets européen
mettre en place une écotaxe et aller
vers une ville sans voiture en 91 il y
avait l'idée qu'il fallait faire des
trans transort en commun efficace des
vélos j'ai découvert ça récemment et ce
sont les lobbyes du pétrole on a la
preuve que ELF et total avaient envoyé
des gens pour désinguer ce projet le
jusqu'à pousser le commissaire européen
la démission donc quand aujourd'hui les
lobby du pétrole nous disent mais nous
on fait on est gentil on fournit du
pétrole parce que la demande de pétrole
augmente on a la preuve qu'ils ont agi
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de trans
d'investissement massif dans les
transports en communs ou ceux qui
auraiit fait baisser qui aurit été bon
pour notre santé et pour notre
portefeuille et pour le climat peut-être
qu'on va se pencher sur ce qu'on peut
faire nous et comment mais vous en
parliz de cette année 2023 année de tous
les records de température sécheresse
incendie pluie diluvienne inondation
tour d'oriseau d'une année sur la
planète parce que en image forcément ça
fait peur ça peut aussi faire agir
regardez c'est signé Hélène
Bonduel c'est une alerte pour la
première fois le 17 novembre dernier la
température mondiale a dépassé de 2 degr
celle de l'air pré industriel un pas
supplémentaire dans le réchauffement
climatique l'Amérique du Sud en ce
moment suffoque sous la chaleur plus de
37 degrés à Brasilia la température la
plus élevée jamais enregistrée au mois
de
novembre il fait très chaud une chaleur
insupportable il n'y a jamais eu de
vague de chaleur aussi forte que celle
qu'on vit actuellement à Brasilia j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est inoui surtout au
printemps généralement il est doux mais
là on a l'impression d'être dans un four
[Musique]
un four aussi dans ces favellas de Rio
où les températures ont frollé les 60
der c'est difficile très difficile
comment vous faites on prend des douches
en permanence on boit de
l'eau la Corne de l'Afrique après avoir
vécu sa pire sécheresse depuis 40 ans
subite à présent des pluies diluvien et
les inondations qui vont avec culture et
bétail dévasté des millions de personnes
déplacé j'avais jamais vu d'inondation
aussi violente avant tout s'est passé si
vite c'est quelque chose qu'ala nous a
infligé partout sur la planète canicule
sécheresses et feux de forêt la terre
brûle et les glaciers fondent après une
visite dans l'Himalaya et en Antarctique
le secrétaire général de l'ONU lance un
cri
d'alarme je suis ici aujourd'hui pour
crier depuis le toit du monde arrêter la
folie les glaciers reculent mais nous ne
faisons rien nous devons mettre fin à
l'aair des combustibles fossiles nous
devons agir maintenant pour protéger les
populations en première ligne et pour
limiter l'augmentation de la température
mondiale à
1,5°gr le monde ne peut pas
attendre car pour le moment selon l'ONU
les engagements climatiques pris par les
pays du monde entier ne permettraient
pas de contenir une hausse des
températures de 2,9 degr au cours de ce
siècle les Falco c'est inatteignable
parce que c'est quoi c'est c'est une
question de de volonté politique qui
n'est pas au rendez-vous c'est une
question d'inacceptabilité des
populations non c'est c'est un peu plus
compliqué que la simple volonté
politique mais disons que enfin je
reviens vraiment au sujet de la COP
parce que ça ça nous montre aussi ce qui
se passe dans les pays des Sud le le on
a un triple problème dans les pays des
Sud c'est que c'est des pays qui
historiquement on peut contribuer quand
même aux émissions de CO2 qui les
subissent aujourd'hui de manière
disproportionnée de fait par rapport à
leurs propres émissions et qui en plus
la tri tri très peu de levierers pour
financer leur adaptation et l'évolution
de leur économie vers des sociétés
bacarbon donc je reviens vraiment à la C
parce que c'est normal qu'on a des
résultats mitigé à la fin ce sont des
arènes diplomatiques la question c'est
comment est-ce que on fait en sorte en
France en Europe d'avoir une position
qui soit pas circonstanciel qui soit
très clair sur le modèle qui est proposé
au pays en développement et
effectivement alors c'est quoi c'est des
c'est des fonds de solidarité pour déjà
s'adapt c'est de c'est quoi c'est des
investissements dans ces pays c'est quoi
c'est des fonds c'est des Fonds
d'adaptation qui aujourd'hui sont censé
exister depuis 2009 he depuis une COP à
à Copenhague quand même he et qui
aujourd'hui ne sont toujours pas
rassemblés 100 milliards qui ne sont pas
rassemblés à la dernière COP la COP 27 à
charmelcheek en Égypte il y a eu aussi
cette histoire de fond de de dommage
perte et dommag qui a été acté mais qui
aujourd'hui est toujours une coquille
vide donc il faut voir les résultats à
la fin de cette COP là et puis
foncièrement il y a aussi la question de
comment est-ce que on organise des
transfert de de fonds de technologie de
tout ce que vous voulez bilatéraux entre
les pays on a des exemples aujourd'hui
entre la France et l'Afrique du Sud
enfin il y a vraiment une diplomatie
environnementale à inventer et c'est là
que l'Europe a vraiment du poids parce
que c'est un horizon à donner au monde
là aujourd'hui concrètement quand vous
regardez un grand nombre de ces pays qui
aujourd'hui sont en souffrance et vont
l'atre de plus en plus ils ont pas
énormément de modèles de développement
ils ont le modèle de développement
proposé par des pétromonarchies qui
passent par ailleurs par tout un tas de
dysfonctionnement structurel aussi de
leur appareil étatique hein ce qui est
important à il faut regarder le le
l'image en entier l'absence au fond de
de solidarité en tout cas de mise en
œuvre des mécanismes de solidarité avec
l'a d'investissement de l'argent de la
coopération avec les moyens pour ces
pays de
s'adapter on le souhaite tous est-ce que
est-ce qu'on on en a les moyens est-ce
que l'Europe a les moyens où est
l'argent pourquoi ça tarde temps c'est
pas une question que d'Europe puisque
dans le cadre justement du fond qui a
été évoqué il y a bien une volonté que
chaque pays du Nord puisse contribuer de
sorte à ce qu'il y a une acceptabilité
dans ces pays du Sud qui ont disons-le
très peu contribué à cette à ces gaz à
effet de serre donc il faut faire
attention de ne pas opposer le Nord et
le Sud parce que c'est une question
d'acceptabilité et d'engagement de
l'ensemble des sociétés mais moi je
pense qu'il faut euh avoir euh dans le
cadre quitte à ce que il y ait peu
d'acceptibilité dans nos propres pays
mais il faut que ces accords ne soient
pas que des feuilles de papier signées
il faut que il y ait des engagements qui
soit fort qui engage chaque pays dans le
cadre de ces accords parce que sinon
nous resterons toujours euh dans des
bilans qui seront mitigés et euh alors
ça ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça
veut dire quoi une super strructure
international qui a les moyens d'imposer
aux état un engagement aussi pour que la
représentation nationale puisse suivre
dans chaque pays quand cette
représentation nationale ou alors des
citoyens qui suivent de manière très
précise les engagements de cette cop de
sorte à ce que il y ait la pression de
la population ah là c'est les moyens
d'agir les outils démocratiques pour
imposer euh de respecter ses engagements
Aurélien Pradier je comprends qu'on on
attache beaucoup d'importance à la COP y
compris symboliquement parce qu'elle est
rentrée dans dans l'atmosphère de notre
vie publique et donc concitoyen même
s'il ne se passionne pas pour la COP
comprennent désormais que c'est là que
des décisions pourrait se prendre je
comprends que symboliquement vous soyez
frappé de cette
hypocrisie de cette insulte presque que
ça représente de le faire à Dubaï mais
la politique de la chaise vide elle est
toujours perdante toujours la bataille
qui est amenée elle nécessite une
présence singulièrement de la parole
française en 1970 George Pompidou est
président de la République un des
premiers discours qu'il prononce c'est à
Chicago on appppelle le discours de
Chicago on est dans une période où il
faut comprendre que la surconsommation
arrive et tout le monde veut son
lav-elinge sa bouteille de coca et
cetera et georgees Pompidou devant tout
ce que Chicago compte
d'économique d'acteurs économique pardon
dit cette société de consommation qui
arrive nous fera perdre la capacité
d'avoir accès au biens élémentaires et
rendra demain la planète invivable à
l'homme c'est en 1970 et depuis quelles
sont vraiment les décisions politique
majeur que nous avons pris sur le sujet
assez peord de Paris a été célébré il
s'apête à fê c'était le dernier mais
c'était c'était il y a 10 ans et on peut
avoir des désaccords politiques nous en
avons sûrement sur la vision de notre
société moi je crois qu'on ne pourra
rien régler demain si on ne pose pas la
question de cette course folle à la
consommation alors vous vous
l'analyserez comme une nécessité de de
décélérer de désindustrialiser moi je
l'analyse pas comme ça pas forcément des
croissantes madame
t trouver des point des points d'accord
mais je pense que la vraie question
c'est celle de la consommation dans le
monde et tout cela ne se règlera pas la
COP tout ça se règlera y compris dans
nos parlements dans nos débats nationaux
pour que chacun de nos concitoyens
puisse trouver des alternatives au modes
de consommation que nous avons
aujourdhui un rapport au temps qui nous
est défavorable oui et puis pardon mais
il y a aussi un rapport de force qui
nous est défavorable vous parliez des
puissances monarchiques du golf elles
n'ont pas de prise sur nous que pour des
questions énergétiques on le voit
aujourd'hui dans la situation
internationale le Qatar est un des
acteurs majeurs du monde en matière
diplomatique pour la libération d'otage
voyez que notre dépendance on vient
d'apprendre aussi que riad est choisi he
pour l'exposition universelle sû que
notre dépendance à cette zone du monde
elle ne concerne pas que le pétrole
malheureusement j'ose dire elle concerne
tous les autres aspects qui ont fait la
puissance française il faut que la
France elle exprime une voix très forte
dans cette COP sur deux sujets mais elle
est pas prête de le faire
malheureusement d'abord c'est la sortie
des énergies fossiles et je dis bien
toutes les énergies fossiles mais comme
le disait très bien pierre Larouturou
que fait la France elle ferme les yeux
voire elle soutient des investissements
privés pour faire de nouveaux forages
aujourd'hui pu ces nouveaux forages ce
sont des bombes climatiques à
retardement donc il faut y aller et il
faut POS Vous total notamment total et
en fait parce que s'il n'y avait que les
Émirats arabes unis ou les puissances du
golf pour continuer l'exploitation à
outrance de toutes les réserves
pétrolières à la rigueur mais le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui à travers
le monde on est en train de mettre en d'
d'investir des milliards des milliards
pour ces projets qui sont des bombes
climatiques à retardement et les pays du
G20 les Nords les pays riches qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils investissent donc ça il
faut que ça s'arrête et moi je trouve
que c'est une des plus grandes c'est
bien plus hypocrite c'est une hypocrisie
bien plus grande que le fait de se dire
que c'est à Dubaï et deuxième chose
deuxème chose absolument indispensable
qu'il faut faire il faut que la France
soit à la hauteur de ses engagements
propres qu'elle fasse en sorte que il y
ait des taxes comme le proposait
jean-pisaniferri et au niveau mondial
aussi qu'elle soutienne fortement la
création d'une imposition
mondial pour financer la transition pour
financer ce nouveau modèle économique
pour financer la décarbonation et pour
faire en sorte d'éviter cette
catastrophe mais des solutions elles
existent et il faudrait que la France
arrive à les mettre en œuvre et que
l'Union européenne aussi qui est en
train de faire volte face et de et de et
de quitter ses engagements climatiques
reprennent la main pour faire en sorte
qu'un nouveau modèle et qu'un modèle
vertueux et solidaire avec le sud puisse
arriver pierre la rou roup vous aurez le
mot de la fin mais très rapidement la
question de trouver des financements est
crucial là on a parlé pour les pays du
Sud qui souffrent du CO2 que nous
l'Europe et les États-Unis on a mis dans
l'atmosphère mais aussi on souvient des
gilets jaunes moi dans mon coin des
Pyrénées il n'y a aucun transport en
commun tous ceux qui celles qui ont du
boulot doivent prendre la voiture pour
aller argelais soit pierfille donc je
comprends très bien si la seule réponse
c'est qu'on va augmenter le prix de
l'essence je comprends que les gens
grognent donc il faut qu'on trouve de
tax monsieur Mad tout le monde donc le
Parlement européen demande par Parlement
euréen vé de Tex cette année pour
demander qu'onte en place enfin la taxe
les transaction financière cette demande
a été repris par William routo le
président du Kenya au nom de tous les
dirigeants africains une petite taxe qui
ne pèserait pas sur monsieur madame tout
le monde une petite taxe sur les marchés
financiers de 01 % rapporterit 60
milliards j'ai fait voter deux fois le
Parlement européen là-dessus à part
l'extrême droite tous les groupes ont
voter
ça la France qui blo aujourdui au
voyz Bruno le d'un mot parce qu'il faut
finir taque sur les les transp du
quotidien qu'il appliquent dans les
Pyrénées Orientales la proposition de
loi que j'ai porté sur les services
express régionaux métropolitains ça
apportera des citoyens nos concitoyens
pousser l'Europe à trouver de l'argent
là où c'est possible sur les
transactions financières voustes
favorable pouss je je suis favorable
c'est pas la première fois que je
m'exprime mais il faut aussi que les
autres pays s'engage comme la France l'a
fait sur la fin l'exploitation et
l'exploration euh
d'hydrocarbur les centrales à charbon
comme nous l'avons fait en France tout à
fait la question c'est quand maintenant
merci beaucoup c'est un débat on va dire
un peu macro mais c'était important de
l'avoir et on va continuer à débattre de
l'écologie avec avec nos nos engagements
nous dans notre pays merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau vous
restez avec moi Aurélien Pradier dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties Pride
nous affranchi ce soir Olivier babo
revient sur sur la révolution tadjbt un
an après son lancement seulement on a
l'impression que ça fait beaucoup plus
la trêve prolongée à Gaza avec la
libération de nouveaux otages on verra
ça avec Vincent eugu et puis de quoi
nous parlez-vous ce soir dans Bourbon
Express alamondaagava je reviens sur la
séance des questions gouvernement
l'hommage à Thomas et la passe d'armes
entre le garde des saau et le
rassemblement national parfait à tout à
l'heure les amis mais d'abord on va
plonger dans votre livre Aurélien
Pradier tenir bon chez bouquin c'est à
vous lire ce que vous disent les
Français que vous croisez aux quatre
coins du pays tenir bon pour dire non à
la réforme des retraites vous revenez
sur cet épisode qui vous a coûté la
vice-présidence des républicains tenir
bon aussi pour ressusciter une droite
populaire sociale antilibérale
anti-immigration comment puisque pour le
moment c'est plutôt Marine Le Pen qui
occupe la place on voit ça avec Marco
Pomier dans son invitation et on en
parle tous les deux juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite au rélien
Pradier c'est parce qu'on s'interroge
sur vos ambitions est sur votre
stratégie étoile montante trublon à
droite trop pressé manque de modestie la
presse ne manque pas de mot pour décrire
votre ascension politique il y a 15 ans
on vous posait déjà la question quant à
un éventuel avenir présidentiel c'est
pas l'ordre du jour on déjà essay d'être
bon conseiller général et puis on verra
la suite après conseiller général a
seulement 21 ans pas de mentor mais une
figure tutellaaire le grand Jacques
comme vous dites sur votre CV à l'époque
un simple bac et une carte de militant
UMP mais votre aventure politique se
poursuit à la mairie de la Bastie Mura
votre bastion puis à l'Assemblée
nationale député depuis 2017 deux grands
combats les violences faites aux femmes
et le handicap marqué profondément par
votre père paraplégique après un AVC on
m'aurait dit que je m'occuperai du
handicap en faisant de la politique
j'aurais sûrement paré que non des
combats des blessures des incertitudes
et un engagement que vous racontez
aujourd'hui dans une autobiographie à
seulement 37 ans mais dans quel but
Aurélien Pradier vous l'enfant prodigue
de la droite devenu l'enfant terrible
pendant l'épisode des retraites opposé à
la réforme malgré l'accord de votre
parti avec le gouvernement est-ce que le
gouvernement a l'intention d'assurer à
toutes celles et ceux en carrière longue
avant 21 ans qu'ils ne feront pas plus
de 43 anné le jour J des voix à droite
manque à l'appel l'exécutif opte pour le
493 Eric cioti fulmine votre échappé
solitaire vous coûtera votre place de
numéro 2 du parti il vaut mieux toujours
payer le prix du courage et de la
liberté que prayer payer le prix de la
compromission être libre dans une
famille politique divisée éclatée encore
aujourd'hui sur le projet de loi
immigration alors quelle pièce du puzzle
êtes-vous Aurélien Pradier où vous
situez-vous entre les inflexibles et les
constructifs ce soir on a une question
pour vous allez-vous pousser à nouveau
le gouvernement au
493 réponse je ne le pousserai pas c'est
lui qui le décidera en tous les cas si
j'ai une opposition dans la clarté je
voterai la motion de censure mais c'est
pas très compliqué encore faut-il
pouvoir la déposer cette motion
aujourd'hui les républicains n'y
parviennent pas il faut 58 députés avec
ces fameux constructifs qu'on a vu dans
cette droite façon puzzle un peu plus
pront à négocier avec le gouvernement ce
projet de loi vous n'y êtes pas c'est
dire à quel point vous êtes faible sur
ce texte en tout cas ilisible est-ce que
la situation de la droite est facile la
réponse est non et je crois qu'elle
restera difficile tant qu'au fond nous
n'aurons pas tranché entre faire la
courte échelle à la fin de la macronie
et reprendre notre liberté il y a un
clivage qui s'installe entre les
rentiers et les aventurier ceux qui
pensent que un aventurier ça on l'
compris avec tous les risques que ça
comporte et je prétends pas que ce soit
une une qualité mais je ne crois pas à
cette idée que l'on puisse se glisser
dans les pantoufles d'Emmanuel
macroner vous pouvez le prendre pour
vous il est personnel mais pour le pays
vous pourriez dire non à un texte sur
l'immigration qui favorise les
expulsions qui aurait permis d'expulser
le meurtrier d'aras avant qu'il ne tue
Dominique Bernard vous pourriez dire ça
à vos électeurs pour être compris
franchement mais c'est faux et voilà
tout le drame ce texte là volet sur les
expulions ce texte là n'aurait pas
permis expulsion du terroriste dont vous
parlez et vous voyez bien verou des 13
ans non c'est faux il n'aurait pas
permis de le faire et c'est d'ailleurs
là que je me suis convaincu depuis des
années ici à l'Assemblée nationale comme
député que les défis étaient trop grands
pour se satisfaire des petits pas en
matière migratoire le défi est trop
grand pour se satisfaire de bricolage
parce que nous le pérons le bricolage
dans quelques mois les Français verront
que tout ça au fond c'est une
distraction porté par Gérald armanin
pour sa carrière politique et que
l'enjeu du pays est secondaire
distraction les mots sont très forts oui
les mots sont forts et je les pèse je
les pèse parce que je je je me fatigue
depuis des semaines de lire iciou là les
commentaires de ce qui compte la
tactique ce qui fera que Gérald daranin
réussira ou pas le conflit entre Géral
d'armanin ellisabeth Bourne tout ça est
dérisoire donc c'est non même dans la
version durci par le Sénat pour version
c'est une version ramoli nous avons posé
un principe simple sur lequel d'ailleurs
tout le monde s'accorde sans réforme de
la constitution de la République nous ne
pouvons pas reprendre la main et moi je
ne me laisserai pas assoupir derrière
des distractions je le dis de la
littérature qui consiste à agiter le
débat public et à être imp vous savez
combien de temps ça prend de réviser la
Constitution est-ce que vous en avez
même les moyens 35e aller-retour Sénat
assemblé congrès vous dites au français
il faudra encore attendre des dizaines
de mois vous leur dites ça le président
de la République a un moyen d'aller vite
c'est le référendum mais alors pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas allé au rencontres de
Saint-Denis Eric Coti à boycotter la
question ericotti mais la décision du
référendum elle ne se prend pas à
Saint-Denis entre quatre murs en
catimini elle se prend à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le Parlement qui peut
décider d'une procédure qui ensuite
débouche sur le référendum vous savez ce
qui aujourd'hui nous abîme profondément
et abîme d'ailleurs sûrement toutes les
grandes démocraties du monde c'est leur
impuissance si nous ne sommes même plus
capables de faire appel au peuple pour
réformer la Constitution face à un
enjeux migratoire alors c'est que nos
démocraties n'ont plus d'avenir et moi
je crois qu'elles ont un avenir alors on
va robiner d'abord est-ce que ça vait un
peu mieux avec Eric cotti oui ça mieux
mais ça n'a jamais été si dramatique que
ça tout est pardonné non rien n'est
pardonné j'ai du mal avec le pardon
c'est une affaire que je réglerai plus
tard celle du pardon mais simplement
nous sommes des responsables politiques
au-delà des conflits on est capable de
se parler vous on va commencer on va
parler de votre livre vous commencez
tout commence dans votre histoire dans
on l'a vu un peu dans le village de la
Bastie de Mura on est dans le Lot vous
êtes né il y a 38 ans c'est une terre de
gauche ça c'est important de le préciser
pour un adolescent de droite et très
jeune vousz vous allez être gagné par la
politique à 8 ans votre père vous emmène
voir le grand Jacques Jacques Chirac
dans une réunion publique à 18 ans vous
délaissez la fac de droit sciencep
Toulouse pour sillonner votre canton en
mobylette et à la surprise générale et
bien vous l'emportez face à votre ancien
prof de primaire ça c'est pas commun V
au fond c'est un parcours duquel je tire
pas de fierté particulière mais si j'ai
voulu faire ce livre c'est aussi pour
remercier tous ceux dont dont j'ai
croisé la personnalité sur mon chemin
euh c'est un parcours assez atypique qui
ressemble je pense à à la démocratie à
la République moi la politique elle a
changé ma vie rien ne me prédestiner à
ça elle m'a permis de montrer qu'il y
avait pas de fatalité et j'avais envie
de le faire partager c'est un livre qui
en fait est assez peu politique Liv
c'est un livre c'est vrai euh personnel
et c'est sans doute les pages les plus
intéressante parce que c'est rare qu'un
un homme politique se se livre sur la
figure paternelle notamment AD admiré
invincible qui sera frappé à vos 16is an
d'un AVC qui le rendra apasique il ne
peut plus parler les mots se sont
involés
oui j'ai en réalité plus connu mon père
ne parlant pas que mon père parlant et
j'ai beaucoup hésité à parler de ça
parce que je déteste une forme
d'impudeur en politique mais je crois
qu'on peut pas bien comprendre les
politiques si on les connaî pas après
chacun jugera de mes positions
politiques les appréciera ou pas mais ce
rapport à mon père cette épreuve de ma
vie qui peut concerner des millions de
Français euh au fond elle m'a structuré
euh je ne dis pas que c'est une gloire
mais je dis simplement que c'est
nécessaire de pouvoir l'expliquer c'est
votre rapport au monde qui change à
partir de ça vous découvrez la
vulnérabilité ou c'est mon rapport à la
fragilité qui change c'est mon rapport
aux autres je vois très vite
l'environnement familial se resserrer je
vois tous ceux et qui nous passion du
temps qui parfois disparaissent d'autres
restent les vrais amis au fond vous êtes
jeté très vite dans une forme de
fatalité et à ce moment-là la politique
est pour moi une manière de me sauver h
avec deux mentors enfin deux modèles
Chirac on en a parlé le grand
Chirac ça c'est très important vous en
parlez beaucoup puis il y a Kessel qui
m'a intéressé Joseph Kessel ça c'est
c'est l'aventure à nouveau oui j'ai
découvert Joseph Kessel un peu tard j'ai
fait assez peu d'études je suis parti
très vite vers l'aventure politique et
Kessel a été pour moi un personnage très
marquant d'abord celui qui écrivait des
pages magnifiques kelle est un écrivain
absolument gigantesque qui est capable
de vous en marqué dans son monde et puis
c un aventurier et puis c'est un homme
qui a porté les couleurs de la France
durant deux guerres sans avoir à
l'origine la nationalité française et je
me suis dit très jeune comment peut-on
aimer à ce point la France n'être pas
français de naissence l'épouser se
battre pour elle et devenir le grand
Joseph Kessel ça a été pour moi une des
grandes révélations de la littérature et
peut-être que ces personnages
d'aventuriers totalement fou vous croyez
au au destin on a l'impression à votre
destin c'est vrai que ça revient souvent
mais vous combattez l'opportunisme au
politique vous ég gratigé beaucoup
jusqu'à Emmanuel Macron Gérald daranin
vous dites il y a pas de fatalisme
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
trouvent que vous êtes un peu pressé et
qu'il y a un peu d'opportunisme chez
vous je sais je ne vois pas très bien où
est-ce qu'il y a l'opportunisme dans
dans mon parcours j'ai porté des
aventures les Lotois m'ont beaucoup
accompagné je leur dois immensément
c'était aussi une manière de les
remercier de ne jamais oublier d' on
vient h HM pour le reste je m'y fais un
peu j'ai un parcours qui n'est pas
habituel je n'ai pas fait les n je ne
viens pas du Conseil d' vous NZ jamais
travaillé si j'ai travaillé dans une
entreprise en dros oui vous êtes passé
de mandat local en mandat local avant de
devenir député devrais-jeen avoir honte
devrais-je avoir honte d'avoir été mère
très jeune d'avoir porté mon parcours de
cette manière-là puis vous savez la la
vie elle vous apprend parfois des choses
très tôt ça a été mon cas en dehors même
de de l'entreprise mais je me suis fait
à cette idée que comme j'étais pas
parfaitement dans le moule il fallait
que je suis beaucoup de critiques et
vous assumez par sont pas toujours
faciles à recevoir pour vous le dire
clairement on peut pas avoir le
sentiment que vous en souffrez c'est pas
extrêmement agréable mais je vais pas me
morfondre ceux qui considèrent que mon
exercice est narcissique sont ceux qui
souvent S sont soumis bien avant moi 38
ans il faut accepter parfois d'être un
peu décrié pour vous situer un peu sur
les chiquier dans la droite
idéologiquement vous défendez une droite
qui se veut populaire sociale
antilibérale hein vous êtes très clair
sur euh les dégâts qui a fait la
mondialisation très ferme très très
ferme sur les questions sécuritaires
immigration qu'est-ce qui vous
différencie vraiment de Marine Le Pen au
beaucoup de choses fondamentales le
rapport aux autres le rapport à la
République le rapport à la France je ne
pense pas que Marine Le Pen aime
profondément la France elle aime une
petite partie elle est pas patriote
Marine Le Pen je pense qu'elle aime
qu'une petite partie de la France
c'estàdime tout quel partie aurait-elle
aimé Joseph Kessel je n'en suis pas
certain et Marine Le Pen n'est pas
l'idéologie que je souhaite épouser
euh pour le reste je ne suis pas
antilibéral je dis simplement comme
George Pompidou l'avait dit en 1970 je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure que la société
de surconsommation permanente écraser
les âmes écraser les individus qu'elle
ne les faisait pas grandir ça c'est pas
une idée euh dé nuuettes de sens c'est
une idée de droite profondément de
droite de quelqu'un qui croit aux hommes
avant de croire euh aux spéculations
très rapidement c'est ma dernière
question en 2007 Nicolas Sarkozi avait
réussi un Grand Paris ramener les
électeurs du rassemblement national vers
vers la droite est-ce qu'il est
réitérable ce Paris qui peut le
remporter aujourd'hui la France est à
droite c'est une
évidence c'est le seul chemin et mon
combat face à Marine Le Pen c'est de
faire en sorte nous verrons mais de
faire en sorte que tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui lui font confiance nous
fasse confiance demain pour ça il faut
une vraie révolution à droite c'est une
révolution populaire il faut que la
droite soit à la fois révolutionnaire
parce que les défis sont trop grands
pour ne pas l'être et populaire parler à
tout le monde du chef d'entreprise
jusqu'à l'ouvrier vrai défi on attend
donc de savoir quel sera le le grand
leader à droite ou pas merci beaucoup
merci Aurélien Pradier tenir bon
c'est-à-dire chez bouquin c'est
personnel c'est politique ça
défourraille pas mal aussi pour ceux qui
aiment les formule choc vous restez avec
moi c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti prix ils vont
vous faire réagir également on les
accueille tout de suite bienvenue les
affranchis Olivier babo de l'Institut
sapiens qui va nous parler de chat GP
qui a 1 an premier anniversaire et puis
Vincent eugux grand reporter on va
revenir sur cette trêve qui se prolonge
à Gaza en échange évidemment de nouveaux
otages libérés on commence par Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est Elsa mondingava qui nous la
raconte ce soir bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je
reviens ce soir sur la séance de
question gouvernement une séance qui a
débuté par une minute de silence un
hommage au jeunes Thomas tu es dans une
fête de village à crépool c'est la
présidente de l'Assemblée yel brun pivé
qui demande ce moment d'hommage pour
Thomas en signe de solidarité avec ses
parents sa famille ses amis ses proches
je vous demande mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les députés de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence alors 7 minutes de silence
évidemment elle a été respectée de
manière unanime on le voit sur les
images sur tous les dans l'hémicycle
elle avait été réclamée par les
républicains dès la semaine dernière
officialisée ce matin en conférence des
présidents elle a été acceptée même si
certains l'ont trouvé un peu tardive mir
voilà la solennité pour cet hommage
collectif à l'assemblée nationale mais
l'unité hein rompu quelques minutes plus
tard dans l'hémicycle exactement la
députée rassemblement national Michelle
Martinez prend la parole elle dénonce le
laxisme de la justice rappelle qu'un des
suspect du meurtre de Thomas avait été
condamné à une peine légère c'est pas la
question la plus polémique he l'histoire
du rassemblement national mais c'est sur
cette question que le garde des saau é
Dupont Moretti décide et bien de se
livrer à une violente charge contre le
rassemblement national écoutez vous
préférez en réalité opposer la France
rurale et tranquille catholique et
blanche à la France des cités la France
des Mohamed des Mouloud et des Rachid
nos frères juifs ont peur nos Frères
musulmans ont peur aussi vos propos sont
incendiaires et ils amènent dans la rue
les militants de l'ultra drroite qui
sont bien plus proches de vous que de
moi pour être crédiible faites le ménage
chassez de vos rangs les gudards les
Identitaires les nazion les racistes les
antisémites alors deux choses
intéressantes pendant que le ministre
parle le sourire de la première ministre
ellisabeth borne qui semble acquesser et
puis on l'a vu sur les images les
députés du rassemblement national qui
quittent l'hémicycle Marine Le Pen
débarque celle des quatre colonnes et
elle annonce qu'elle va pas porter
plaines la réponse est
hordurière nous ne nous n'entendons pas
nous laisser insulté par un ministre
quel qu'il soit car encore une fois en
tant que député nous sommes les
représentants du peuple français est-ce
que vous vous rendez compte de la
gravité de son propos tout de même ce
propos est absolument inadmissible et
nous n'entendons pas l'accepter
d'ailleurs et et encore une fois il en
répondra il en répondra devant la
justice on le sait du pont meréti il est
en attente d'une autre décision qui sera
rendue demain elle pourrait scellerler
son sort au sein du gouvernement alors
c'était peut-être le dernier Barou
d'honneur pour le ministre de la Justice
et on le voit il a voulu vraiment axer
les choses sur son combat son combat
contre le rassemblement national merci
beaucoup els a une réaction après la
mort de de Thomas ERC Dupont moriti
est-ce qu'il a raison de dire que le le
RN oppose cette France rurale catholique
et blanche à la France des cités des
Mohamed et des mouloudes Éric Dupont
Moretti est est devenu l'idiot utile de
Marine Le Pen j'espère qu'il s'en rend
compte toute cette mise en scène a rendu
service au rassemblement national c'est
ce que vous voulez Éric de pomoretti en
se faisant plaisir comme il l'a fait il
l'a fait monter pour vous bien sûr mais
c'est une évidence il le voulant ou pas
il leur sert la soupe qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé des réactions du
rassemblement national d'éc Zemour je
vais vous dire c'est c'est insupportable
c'est insupportable parce que un gamin a
été assassiné parce que partout dans
notre pays nous av une montée de
l'ultraviolence partout que la seule
réponse que nous y donnons ce sont des
minutes de silence qui je vous le dis
comme je le pense me fatigue m'exaspère
tant de débat pour savoir si nous allons
avoir une minute de silence ou pas et
c'est le spectacle d'une garde des saau
ministre de la Justice de la République
qui rend un service immense à G des saau
qui dénonce aussi le comportement
incendiaire ce sont ces mots de certains
à la droite radicale à l'extrême droite
franc pouremour radia pour Marine Le Pen
Eric chotti qui a eu bien du mal à
condamner les descentes de l'ultra
droite à à roman suriser et vous ne me
ferez pas choisir je condamnerai avec
l'absolue fermeté nécessaire l'acte
ignoble qui a concerné ce gamin et je
condamnerai avec l'absolue fermeté sans
aucune hésitation ces milices qui
aujourd'hui veulent se faire justice à
la place de la République mais il y a
pas une seule seconde d'hésitation quel
est ce pays quelle est cette démocratie
dans laquelle désormais on voudrait
hésiter à dénoncer ou des milices ou
l'assassinat d'un gamin je ne choisis
pas entre les deux je veux que les deux
cessent parce que ce quoi je crois c'est
l'ordre républain risque de basculement
comme l'a dit Olivier verrand dans la
société il a raison c'est un basculement
vers l'ultraviolence il n'y a pas un
sujet de violence dans notre pays qui
n'a pas pris un cran supplémentaire vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur les violences
conjugales quasiment tous les
féminicides sont aujourd'hui précédés
d'actes de torture de barbarie nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui un seul
règlement de compte qui ne soit pas
précé précédé souvent d'actes de torture
vous voyez bien que Mame votre
diagnosticque ça vient d'où ça relève de
quoi la la décivilisation comment ça
s'explique c'est l'accoutumance ce que
nous avons à l'ultraviolence et le défi
la guerre de civilisation dont beaucoup
parlent n'est pas une guerre de religion
c'est la guerre entre ceux qui attache
de l'importance à la vie humaine et ceux
qui n'en attachent pas sur la situation
internationale dont vous parlerez
sûement on y va la question des otages
est absolument effrayante nous sommes en
train de nous habituer à ce que les vies
humaines ne valent presque plus alors
une transition parfaite pour cette
chronique de Vincent vouz revenir
justement sur cette trêve qui se
prolonge des otages à nouveau libérés
une méthode qu'on découvre euh sous le
sous les yeux du monde si l'on vous
avait promis qu'en ce 28 novembre 50 des
240 otage raflé par le Hamas lors de son
équipée barbare aurait recouvré la
liberté et que plus plusieurs dizaines
peuvent espérer un dénouement analogue
et bien vous auriez signé dè demain et
moi aussi chacun devine l'immense
soulagement des intimes à la mesure de
l'angoisse dévorante qui hantaiit leur
jour blême et leur nuit sans sommeil pas
de quoi pour autant céder à l'euphorie
car le plus rude reste à venir à en
juger par la gestion tout en cynisme de
son stock de captif par le mouvement de
la résistance islamique ces stratèges
ont pris soin jusqu'àors d'abréger le
calvaire de femmes d'enfants et d'ados B
nationaux de préférence tel est le cas
d'itan Herz Sahar les trois mineurs
franco-israéliens rendus au leur hier
lundi ils ont aussi relâché sans
contrepartie une vingtaine de
travailleurs asiatiques thaïlandais pour
la plupart dans l'espoir de s'assurer la
bienveillance des nations du Sud et
alors vous nous dites que la suite
serait plus aléatoire ou pas oui du fait
du profil des 180 kidnappés dont le
cauchemar se prolonge cuid des hommes
cuid des détenus israéloisraéliens cuid
de la restitution des dépouilles des
otages décédés cuide enfin des soldats
de tsal nul doute que pour ceci le Hamas
durcira le barê appliqué jusqu'à lors à
savoir trois prisonniers palestiniens
élargis pour un captif libéré au fil des
jours le marchandage humain risque de se
faire plus âpre d'autant qu'à fleur un
autre facteur d'inquiétude tout indique
que certains des disparus de Gaza sont
au mains d'autres factions radicales
telles le Djihad islamique ou le FPLP
Front Populaire de Libération de la
Palestine voir de gangs locaux av de
monayer leur butin et conséquences pour
le Hamas selon vous affaiblie sur le
plan militaire forcément est-ce que ça
peut être un Regin politique ben quoi
qu'il advienne demain et la morale du
tel y laissit des plumes par brasser les
assassins du 7 octobre ont marqué des
points bien sûr les tractations transit
pour l'essentiel via leur bienfaiteur
Catari épaé en cela par l'Égypte et les
États-Unis il n'en Aure pas moins que
l'État hébreux se voit contraint de
traiter avec un ennemi qu'il a juré
d'anéantir et qui de plus redort au sein
des masses arabes un blason pour le
moins terni la brutalité extrême de
l'aripos de Tsahal fatale à des milliers
de civils palestiniens grossira à coup
sûr les rangs des Vengeurs et des VAT en
guerre quant au retour au foyer de
centaines de prisonniers il se
rapportait au crédit du Hamas jamais on
avait vu tant de ces drapeaux verts
flottter dans le ciel de s Jordanie et
pourtant et pourtant quoi et pourtant
une chercheuse de l'Université Princeton
amané Jamal vient de dévoiler le verdict
d'une enquête d'opinion d'ailleurs
écourtée par le carnage d'octobre le son
numéro 1 la majorité des Palestiniens
rejettent dans un même mouvement
l'occupation israélienne et la dictature
du Hamas plus des 2 tiers des Gazaoui
sondé disent faire peu ou pas confiance
aux maîtrre de la bande et la plupart
imputent leurs épreuves du quotidien à
l'incompétence et à la corruption du
pouvoir islamiste plus qu'au blocus
implacable d'ailleurs infligé depuis
2007 par Israël quen sera-t-il demain
mystère merci beaucoup merci Vincent de
relayer ce travail précieux de cette
chercheuse à Gaza à l'heure où aucun
journaliste n'est n'est admis dans dans
le territoire on termine avec vous un
peu moins de temps mais tout aussi
intéressant premier anniversaire de Chad
jpti la révolution de l'intelligence
artificielle est parmi nous un an et
toutes ces dents peut-être que les
historiens diront plus tard que le 21e
siècle a vraiment commencé en novembre
2022 le 30 novembre 2022 Chad GPT 3.5
open a été publié par open e et a fait
entrer le monde dans une phase
d'accélération absolument inouï depuis
le 18e siècle les cyclles d'innovation
RAC
les machines à vapeur et le rail on se
souvient l'électricité puis la
pétrochimie puis Internet et maintenant
l'intelligence artificielle le passage
de l'air d'Internet à l'air de l'a avait
pris 20 ans et là on voit que désormais
les innovations se comptent plutôt en
mois voir voire en semaine alors en quoi
c'est une véritable révolution alors il
y aura évidment beaucoup à dire mais
très rapidement jusque-l les
technologies remplacai les tâches peu
qualifié la grande nouveauté c'est qu'il
y a génératif puisque c'est de cela dont
il s'agit remplace des tâches
intellectuelles et créatifes d'assez
haut niveau VO de très très haut niveau
le travail se très se transforme déjà à
l'heure où on en parle dans le tertière
il manque la productivité et parfois il
remplace des tâches voire certains
emploi dans dans certains cas des tâches
intellectuelles complexes peuvent être
automatisés lia peut programmer dessiner
concevoir des projets de contrat des
textes de toutes sortes les applications
sont infinies on va ensuite entrer
rapidement dans l'air des assistants
humanoïdes les progrès foudroyants de la
robotique mettront dans nos foyers dans
nos bâtiments public et partout en fait
he des robots formme humaine qui
accompliront 1000 tâches nettoyage
entretien cuisine soin un soutien
scolaire c'est évidemment assez assez
inoui hein on peut penser que liia nous
permettra d'accélérer le progrès
technologique et scientifique aussi ça
qui pourrait nous faire entrer dans une
boucle exponentielle d'avancé les
technologies du vivant pourrait faire un
bon et notre longévité avec elle et
menace associé à ces révolutions
technologique oui ah oui il a
effectivement il il y a une face obscure
à cette à cette médaille les risques
portés sont sont innombrables aussi hein
domination militaire de pays ennemis qui
disposeraiit de meilleures technologie
manipulation en tout genre absence de
pluralisme des sources d'information
affaiblissement physique et intellect
d'individus constamment assistés et puis
allons encore encore plus loin une
grande majorité de chercheurs sont
aujourd'hui convaincus que l'IA nous
dépassera dans tous les domaines mais il
y a un grand en gros il y a deux camps
il y a ceux qui disent que liya est
tellement dangereuse qu'il faut la
freiner qu'il faut la réguler lourdement
et ceux qui pensent qu'il faut avancer
et pensent que les avantage dépasserons
les inconvénients le patron la recherche
de Microsoft Eric orvitz nous implore de
prendre des mesures pour limiter le
risque et en face sal Hatman a écrit
cette été qu'il est convaincu que la
super intelligence artificielle sera là
avant 2030 il est dans le camp des
accélérationnistes vient gagner son bras
de fer contre le conseil
d'administration d'OPA puis qu'il a viré
le conseil d'administration et il est
resté c'est donc pour l'instant le camp
accéléroniste ACC les rationistes qui
gagnent bonne chance à tous et qui nous
inquiète particulièrement merci beaucoup
Olivier babo il va nous falloir de
grands hommes pas forcément des hommes
forts mais de grands hommes face à ce
chaos du monde et et à ces abîmes
technologiques alors peut-être en
vousette prétion en tout cas si vous
voulez vous faire une idée sur une
trajectoire et une ambition tenir bon
c'est-àdire aux éditions boucin très
belle soirée et à
[Musique]
demain